اسمي أديلينا جويسي، أنا
مصممة أزياء ومصممة أزياء نصفها إنجليزي ونصف أردني
وأقيم حاليًا في عمان بالأردن بعد أن
عملت سابقًا مع فيكتوريا
بيكهام في لندن. قررت العودة إلى
الأردن في عام 2017.
وكان أول عرض لي في أسبوع التصميم الرجالي
في عام 2017.  حيث شرفتني الأميرة دريم
بزيارة معرضي
وهي من الداعمين المتحمسين للمرأة
في الصناعات الإبداعية ونحن
نتعاون منذ أن كانت
العائلة المالكة من كبار الداعمين
للأزياء والتصميم في جميع أنحاء العالم
وخاصة المصممين المحليين وكذلك
المصممين الأردنيين الذين
جلسوا معهم  الأميرة ريم والأميرة
جوليلا اللتان تتمتعان
برؤية شغوفة للغاية بالموضة وتعرفان حقًا
ما يحلو لهما، قررنا أن
نختار معًا اتجاهًا معينًا وهو
شيء كان عبارة عن صورة ظلية خالدة
تتميز
بالنعومة والسيولة واللمعان الخفيف،
لذلك كان ذلك مع  تلاعب
الزخارف على الملابس وأيضا
اللون الذي يناسب عمر الأميرة جولييتا
وكذلك لون بشرتها
يأتي من خلفية التصميم والأناقة
أرى الملابس كشكل من أشكال الهوية
وطريقة للتعبير عن أنفسنا
أسلوب العائلة المالكة يسمح لنا بالفرز
للتعرف عليهم من خلال اختيارهم
للملابس،
أعتقد أن أفضل طريقة يمكنني وصفها بها
هي عمل فني جميل
يجمع بين الهوية والأسلوب معًا في مثل هذا
اليوم التاريخي، حيث يمثل
تاريخ الموضة جزءًا كبيرًا من
حياتنا كمبدعين ومصممين،
ونحن  لدينا الكثير من الملابس الأساسية التي
نرتديها جميعًا كل يوم اليوم والتي جعلتها
أيقونات مميزة، على سبيل المثال قد يكون
لدينا قميص أبيض نرتدي جميعًا
قميصًا أبيض أصبح مميزًا بواسطة
الممثل جيمس دين أو لدينا
النظارات الشمسية كبيرة الحجم التي جعلتها أيقونة
جاكي كينيدي وبالطبع
لدينا الليدي ديانا التي جعلت حقيبة القابض مميزة
والعائلة المالكة على وجه الخصوص
بالطبع الملكة رانيا الملكة هي واحدة
من هؤلاء النساء والأيقونات التي
ستظل في التاريخ كمرجع
الموضة والأناقة
الأجنبية